was für ein ja ich möchte euch in diesem
video mit nehmen und euch zeigen was in
unserem selbstversorger ja so richtig
gut geklappt hat und was absolut
schiefgegangen ist also kommt mit wir
gehen raus ich erzähle euch ein bisschen
wie 2009 10 so für uns gelaufen
für diejenigen von euch die jetzt noch
gar nicht wissen was wir überhaupt
machen wir versuchen möglichst viel von
dem was wir essen selbst zu erzeugen
werden großen gemüsegarten wir kaufen
quasi gar kein gemüse messung
wir haben viele obstbäume und
beerensträucher für die obst
selbstversorgung südfrüchte kaufen wir
natürlich noch zu ab und so haben wir
auch lust auf bananen aber wir versuchen
eben möglichst viel selbst zu machen wir
kochen komplett selbst also
fertiggerichte und sowas gibt's bei uns
überhaupt nicht wir halten die hühner
für eier und ich habe ziegen die ich
merke ich mache meinen käse selber also
frischkäse väter camembert eis butter
joghurt und so weiter und so versuchen
wir eben möglichst viel von dem was wir
essen selbst zu erzeugen getreide und
ölfrüchte und so was waren wir nicht an
dass wir uns zu aufwendige machen das
vor allem weil es einfach spaß macht und
irgendwoher das ganze dann auf also ich
hatte irgendwie keine lust getreide zu
brechen
ich weiß nicht ob das irgendwer von euch
macht ihr machen das so weit wie es uns
eben spaß und freude macht und das ist
auch der hauptgrund warum wir das machen
er ist einfach bei super super schön ist
mit der ganzen familie an der frischen
luft zu sein wirklich gutes essen zu
haben alte sorten anzubauen die wirklich
noch nach was schmecken zu wissen dass
die tiere die man hält so glücklich und
frei waren wie es nur irgendwie geht und
dass das essen was auf dem tisch landet
einfach richtig richtig gut ist wenn ihr
mehr zum thema selbstversorgung wissen
wollt dann abonniert gerne meinen kanal
damit ihr informiert werde sobald das
nächste video erscheint drückt immer
auch die glocke damit ihr dann wirklich
eine benachrichtigung bekommt während
vor ziemlich genau einem jahr hierher
umgezogen und hier da die an dem großen
garten hat und tiere zur
selbstversorgung hält er weiß dass das
ganz schön viel arbeit ist alles neu
aufzubauen also wir mussten den garten
neu anlegen hier der ganze küchengarten
den haben wir im frühling erst angelegt
dann mussten wir ein gewächshaus bauen
wir mussten neue weiden für die tiere
suchen unserem stelle kümmern und so
weiter
und das war schon ganze brocken arbeit
es ist irgendwie schade wenn man sich
irgendwo was aufgebaut hat und das alles
zurücklassen muss und komplett neue
irgendwo anfangen wo ist und auch hier
wissen wir dass wir nicht so lange
bleiben werden also fürs nicht noch fünf
jahre
und ja es ist schade wenn man nie so
einen ort hat wo man dann dauerhaft
bleiben kann also ich freue mich schon
sehr wenn ich irgendwann mal irgendwo
ankomme wo es sich dann auch richtig
lohnt bäume zu pflanzen und feste zäune
zu bauen und richtig ja sich richtig
schön zu machen das war also unsere
erste herausforderung der umzug das ging
aber eigentlich viel besser als erwartet
also wir konnten den alten garten
behalten das ist jetzt unser acker davon
habe ich euch ja schon erzählt und das
ist eigentlich das wichtigste weil wenn
du so viel arbeit und zeit und liebe ein
stück land steckt dann ist es sehr hart
das wieder herzugeben und so können wir
das immer noch weiter nutzen und davon
profitieren dass wir da einfach ein
super fruchtbaren garten angelegt haben
und richtig viel platz haben hier im
garten hat sich eigentlich alles
ziemlich schnell eine gruft ich weiß
nicht wenn man ein gewisses level von
erfahrungen erreicht hat im garten dann
funktioniert es einfach viel besser also
am anfang hatten wir noch viel mehr
probleme ich wusste nicht so richtig wie
ich was an bauer aber mittlerweile ja
war das jetzt auch kein problem hier im
garten
obwohl das das erste jahr war wo wir
hier gewertet haben wirklich gute
erträge zu erzielen das hat alles
ziemlich gut geklappt also das war auf
jeden fall ein kursabschluss punkt jetzt
kommt schon wieder so ein bus daher
gefahren man heute ist richtig krach
ihren ich bin ein bisschen unzufrieden
damit wie ich das gewächs ausgenutzt
habe ja dass ist ein bisschen schade
dass da jetzt so wenig wächst aber das
wird nächstes jahr schon viel besser es
war einfach viel los und dann ist das so
ein bisschen hinten runtergefallen
aber das kriegen wir alles noch hinter
die sache die dieses jahr mit am
schönsten war liegt absolut an euch das
war der gemüsegarten staaten onlinekurs
es hat mir so so so viel spaß gemacht
denn für euch zu drehen und den mit euch
durchzugehen euch zu helfen in euren
garten fragen und vor allem zu sehen was
ihr in eurem garten alles geschafft habt
ihr könnt so so stolz darauf sein es ist
mein allergrößtes ziel mehr menschen zu
zeigen wie sie ihr eigenes essen anbauen
und wie sie mit der natur arbeiten statt
gegen die natur und zusehen wie ihr
diese anleitungen bei euch umgesetzt
habe dass sie es einfach gemacht habe
dass ihr so so viel geschafft habe und
eure ganzen fotos zu sehen und die
ganzen texte die im magic das ist so
ihr könnt gar nicht ahnen wie glücklich
mich das macht ich kann es kaum abwarten
dass es nächsten frühling weitergeht und
ich neue teilnehmer in den kurs
aufnehmen wir haben da jetzt auch noch
ganz viele neue videos gedreht also wenn
du im gemüsegarten staaten mit dabei ist
dann schau auf jeden fall jetzt nochmal
rein weil wir haben zwei komplett neue
module und andere module aufgehübscht
haben noch viel mehr gedreht jetzt den
sommer über einfach um das ganze noch
mehr abzurunden und noch mehr für euch
da zu sein ich habe jetzt schon seit
über 13 jahren ziegen und kein jahr war
bisher so schlimm wie dieses das ist ein
absoluter flop gewesen
das mag zum beispiel an diesem kleinen
kandidaten hier wo einst unserer lämmer
die wir dieses jahr bekommen haben und
man kann setzen wir uns nicht an kann
man nicht lassen
frank wieder runter also wir hatten
dieses jahr fünf lämmer und wir hatten
dieses jahr fünf flaschen länger weil
eine ziege gestorben ist das war meine
allerliebste milchziegen curry ist die
diejenigen die meinen blog genauer
verfolgen kennen carey auf jeden fall
ich beende mein bild ein
die war super super lieb und süß und die
hat leider gebärmutterkrebs bekommen als
sie trächtig war die hatte drei lämmer
in ihrem bauch und wir wussten nicht ob
dies schaffen werden überhaupt auf die
welt zu kommen ob curry das ganze
überlebt sie hat die geburt überlebt
also wir mussten nach helfen und die
lämmer rausholen aber carey hat überlebt
nur sie ist danach nicht mehr
aufgestanden und ist ein paar wochen
nach der geburt leider gestorben
das war richtig dramatisch und dann
hatte ich noch eine andere trächtige
ziegen anna heißt die die ist schon bei
mir geboren und die ist super alt also
dies für eine richtige oma wenn man die
so anguckt dann denkmal wo man sieht es
ihr einfach an dass sie schon in die
jahre gekommen ist und sie sollte
eigentlich nicht gedeckt werden das ist
leider doch passiert sie hat in der
trächtigkeit ja immer weiter abgebaut
ich war mir auch nicht sicher wie das
lauf
wird sie hat dann dilemma ohne probleme
auf die welt gebracht aber überhaupt
nicht angenommen das heißt dann hatten
wir das ist zb bo und seine schwester
elli die auch mit der flasche aufgezogen
werden mussten und das war hart ich
wünsche mir das immer dass die tiere bei
ihren müttern bleiben können dass sie
auf natürliche weise aufgezogen werden
können aber in dem fall ging das nicht
anderes ersten teil blieb der kleine bo
aber seiner schwester hat man es zum
park angemerkt dass sich von menschen
aufgezogen wurde weil die ganz schnell
aggressiv wurde die hatte gar keinen
respekt mehr vor menschen
die habe ich jetzt zum glück gegen die
braune zinke dahinten getauscht dann ist
er jetzt eine große herde gekommen wo
sie gar nicht so viele menschen kontakt
hat und ich habe dafür eine tolle milch
zu bekommen das war wirklich ein erfolg
also die wo sie da hinten
die habe ich jetzt seit september oder
ungefähr seit dem spätsommer und das war
auch ganz schön schwer die einst zu
merken aber seitdem läuft das so gut und
die gibt uns ganz viel tolle mich und
ich bin ganz ganz dankbar dafür dass das
jetzt so gut geklappt hat gerade auch
weil ich im frühling als curry gestorben
ist schon mal eine andere mächtige
gekauft habe mit der ist überhaupt nicht
funktioniert hat die war einfach viel zu
scheu und hatte auch noch zwei lämmer
dabei das hat gar nicht geklappt und die
war super ausbruch freudig also sich
hier haben wir sind hier am campingplatz
mit der weide und die ziegen haben
ständig den campingplatz geplündert ich
hatte da richtig probleme auch mit den
besitzern weil die das überhaupt nicht
lustig fanden kann ich verstehen
ich habe schon die höchsten zäune da ist
immer strom drauf die ziegen haben wir
alles was sie brauchen aber irgendwie
seitdem die herausgefunden haben dass
sie hin campingplatz brötchen aus den
zelten klauen können ja war es um sie
geschehen und die waren ständig da das
heißt dann konnte ich leider diese neue
züge nicht behalten also die ließ sich
nicht merken und die ständig abgehauen
das war schon ein ganz schöner flop aber
dafür haben wir jetzt ruhe sie elli ist
in guten händen und so hat sich nochmal
alles zum guten gewendet wo sie ist eine
würdige nachfolgerin für karry das muss
ich auf jeden fall sei eigentlich so
lieb und so süß aber alles in allem war
es bei den siegen
etwas durchwachsen dieses jahr und es
sind sehr viele tränen geflossen ja ich
hänge so an denen ich liebe jede
einzelne vom 17 und wenn der dann
irgendwas passiert das ist schlimm dass
es wirklich hart was richtig gut
geklappt hat ist unsere vorkammer
situation wir haben super viel haltbar
gemacht ich mache mir da jedes jahr
immer einen plan weil wir eben auch im
winter ganz viel aus dem eigenen garten
essen wollen und da habe ich
mittlerweile ziemlich gut raus wie viel
wir von was essen ja wir hatten nach
einigen niederlagen beim ausbringen von
krücken dann doch noch erfolg hier sind
die zwei küken die wir jetzt für
nächsten frühling ausgebrütet haben das
ist eine ganz tolle schwedische rasse
die grüne eier legt schwedische ist bei
heißen die und das ist auf jeden fall
mega siehst ich den hier im kinderzimmer
werden auch immer viel gekuschelt und
betitelt und das war echt dann
letztendlich doch noch ein großer erfolg
auch wenn wir sehr arge probleme hatten
weil ich einen neuen inkubator
ausprobiert habe hüpfen eure küken auch
immer auf die wärme platten und kacken
alles voll
ja ich habe einen neuen inkubator
ausprobiert der leider zu warm war der
hat die richtige temperatur angezeigt
aber viele der küken hatten
missbildungen die eindeutig darauf
zurückzuführen sind dass ist beim brüten
zu warm war und das war echt sehr sehr
sehr schade und ich bin sehr froh dass
die beiden jetzt sowohl auf sind ihr
seid zucker sie ist circa sie ist alles
in allem bin ich sehr zufrieden mit
unserem jahr es war sehr sehr schön wir
hatten richtig viel spaß bei fast allen
sachen die wir gemacht haben auch wenn
die rückschläge hatten fand ich was
generell betrachtet ein wirklich gutes
jahr
gerade wenn man tiere hält dann gehört
das einfach wirklich dazu
selbstversorgung ist hart und findet
ihre hetze passiert immer wieder misst
du musst mit tod umgehen du musst mit
kranken tieren umgehen es passieren
sachen die du nicht vorhersehen kann das
gehört irgendwie
wer einfach mit dazu wir haben dieses
jahr nicht so viele sachen neu
ausprobiert weil wir schon an so einem
level der selbstversorgung angekommen
sind wie wir es eigentlich gerne haben
also so viel mehr wollen wir gar nicht
machen aber ich kann mir vorstellen
nächstes jahr mit kaninchen anzufangen
und irgendwann hätte ich auch gerne
schweine aber das ist noch wirklich ein
traum
dafür haben wir noch nicht die
infrastruktur oder die flächen das kommt
dann irgendwann in der zukunft ich freue
mich zu hören wie ein jahr gelaufen ist
schreibt mir das gerne mal unten in die
kommentare
schreibt mir mal auf was ihr euch für
nächstes jahr vornimmt was wir anders
machen wollt was ist gut gelaufen was es
nicht so gut gelaufen
dann können wir da unten ein bisschen
plaudern ich freue mich immer von euch
zu hören
abonniert den kanal drückt die glocke
geben ihr den daumen nach oben wenn es
euch gefallen hat ich freue mich riesig
auf nächstes jahr mit euch das ganze gar
ein jahr von anfang bis ende und das
ganze selbstversorger ja mit euch durch
zu leben und da auch von euch zu hören
was ihr nächstes jahr macht es hat
wirklich viel spaß gemacht bisher mit
dem youtube kanal dankeschön ganz tolles
feedback danke dass wir schon so viele
abonnenten jetzt auf dem kanal haben ich
wünsche euch ein ganz schönes
silvesterfest macht's gut